cette année nous allons probablement
jeter tous réunis plus de 540 mille
tonnes de sacs cadeaux ou de papier
d'emballage
une fois les fêtes terminées du papier
qui ne se recyclent pas forcément ou
bien qui vient engorgé des centres de
tri déjà saturé une solution facile
oui on peut suivre les cinq grands
principes du zéro déchet vous pourrez
tout simplement retourner dans le temps
et aller voir du côté de nos ancêtres
qui avait quelques bonnes idées d'abord
art et en asie on suit si le troisième
grand principe du zéro déchet
réutilisées tout ce qui peut avoir une
deuxième vie avec la technique japonaise
du foro chikhi on utilise un morceau
tissu ça peut être un foulard un morceau
de chiffon pas troller un bandana
vous avez le choix même chose avec le bo
gadji coréen
vous avez besoin d'un morceau de tissu
et de pratiquer votre savoir faire
manuel sinon à la maison vous pouvez
aussi utiliser de vieux emballages comme
des mappemondes par exemple ou de vieux
magazines
vous pouvez aussi vous en servir pour
faire des rubans comme ceci bien sûr les
bons vieux journaux feront aussi
toujours la faire ou d'utiliser une
vieille chemise ou un chandail qui
traînent dans votre armoire son but réel
pour décorer vos emballages suivez les
principes 3 4 et 5 des zéro déchet
réutiliser recycler et composter au
besoin par exemple remplacer le ruban
adhésif par un morceau de ficelle prenez
des matériaux naturels des feuilles
tombées des arbres des pommes de pin des
bd branche de cèdre ou de pain que vous
pourrez ensuite remettre à mère nature
une fois l'emballage des faits mais
avant nous lancer dans tout ça on
pourrait d'abord se demander
honnêtement at on vraiment besoin d'en
bas les tous nos cadeaux